[Musique]
une marche funèbre à la mémoire de john
floyd la veille du procès du policier
accusé de son meurtre pas de justice pas
de paix scandaient manifester car le
monde entier a été témoin de la mort en
direct de josh freed ce 25 mai de 1 un
homme noir agonisant sous le genou d'un
policier blanc imperturbable durant huit
minutes 46 une image qui a réveillé les
consciences et enflammé l'amérique
arrêté quatre jours après pour homicide
involontaire
derek chauvin libéré sous caution en
attendant son procès aujourd'hui le
tribunal de minneapolis ressemble à une
véritable forteresse des barrières et
des barbelés ont été érigé tout autour
plus de mille soldats de la garde
nationale sont mobilisés un procès placé
sous haute surveillance qui aura lieu
dans la plus grande salle d'audience du
tribunal
la mort de john floyd a réveillé des
vieux démons ici ont des rôles les noms
des quatre cent vingt neuf victimes de
violences policières au minnesota dans
les vingt dernières années malgré une à
une elles défilent devant le micro pour
raconter leur histoire
elle se souvient de la date et du nombre
de coups de feu tirés elle n'oublie pas
non plus les noms des policiers
impliqués ou un véhicule à l'avancé donc
jusqu'à la lie quand ils tuent nos
crochets une famille entière vite elles
c'est toute une communauté qui meurt et
qui relate fire violée ils nous ont volé
quelque chose qu'on ne retrouvera jamais
des stellistes bestgen
le ministre doit être placé sous enquête
fédérale
ces meurtres après meurtre après meurtre
et ces gens là sont libres valérie
castille a perdu son fils fils enzo il
ya près de cinq ans
c'était le 6 juillet 2016 un homme est
interpellé car ses feux arrière ne
fonctionne pas et n'a pas ou jack is it
is comin il se fait tirer dessus par le
policier alors qu'il va chercher ses
papiers sa conjointe diffuse la scène en
direct sur facebook là le policier
geronimo yanez est acquitté comme péter
il aurait dû être condamné dit elle
mohammed nour est le seul policier à
avoir été condamnée au mini sauta pour
avoir tué une citoyenne le seul policier
en prison et noir dit elle parce qu'il a
commis le péché ultime tuer une personne
blanche ouailles à diochon las vegas la
colère est grande les attentes aussi
tous les regards sont tournés vers le
procès de derek chauvin il symbolise à
lui tout seul le procès que toutes ces
familles n'ont pu obtenir et elles
veulent des réponses ici à 0 des guerres
qui serait du canada minneapolis